on va tout de suite joué à tarte et
fenêtres
[Applaudissements]
alors la jouer dans ce sens là bien
entendu un voilage ont choisi quelques
uns
sachez qu'il ya la fenêtre numéro une
lafayette numéro 2 la fenêtre numéro 3
vous allez pouvoir gagner de très très
bons cadeaux ici autour de la table vous
allez pouvoir jouer pour une personne du
public chaque fois il n'y a personne du
public partira ou avec un cadeau ou bien
vous prendre un truc dans la tronche
état d'accords m'échappe mais chérie
c'est récent mais j'allais devoir
choisir la fenêtre une deux ou trois
derrière deux fenêtres
il ya des trucs pourris derrière une
fenêtre il ya un cadeau formidable et on
est dans tes pmp on est gâté mais c'est
vrai on est dans des pme et des ménages
soit là non plus pour enfiler des perles
donc deux tartes sur un canot à quai qui
veut des maris qui peut démarrer
seuls 10
[Applaudissements]
c'est un bonheur des nouvelles actions
d'une demoiselle qui est avec nous leurs
essais pas pour lui le micro mercredi un
micro merci merci d'être là en tout cas
c'est super sympa que vous soyez dans
l'émission vraiment merci
alors alors attendre à ce qu est la dame
elle vient de voir castaldi est elle à
la regarder elle a regardé à fait comme
ça mon dieu comment comment vous appelez
sans besoin il sauva son vin oui vous
êtes contente d'être là sa vie va vous
faire un petit bisou
oui c'est vrai il est comme tous les
sens qui nous regardent sandra qu'est ce
que vous faites dans la vie chez aides
soignantes jet magnifique inter
franchement si vous êtes magnifique
jouer à l'étranger des yeux magnifiques
vous savez lire hyper ému c'est parce
qu'envoyer benjamin castaldi en veille
ah non rafa mars c'est pour tout le
monde c'est vous êtes fidèle à ce que je
vois tous les soirs tous les
chroniqueurs tous vous êtes en amour
souvent et que la vue de tous les ce et
je suis venu trois jours experts restent
avec nous trois jours alors oui
[Applaudissements]
il est beau il est beau c'est ce que
disent toutes ces femmes
alors vous allez pouvoir gagner son drap
un très beau cadeau en plus je suis très
content cette aide soignante on embrasse
toutes les oreilles non qui nous
regardent ils font un travail
exceptionnel et mais franchement et
regardez vous avez vu comme elle est
magnifique mais attention tu ne touches
pas seuls à payer sur tous les coups
vous êtes mariés nous avions c'est non
plus cette célibataire une heure ce qui
t'arrive tu vois quand même alors
attention vous allez pouvoir gagner ou
une enceinte bluetooth une tôle en
trottinette électrique - casque ou d'une
tablette tactile à contrer l'évasion une
caméra de sport une console de jeu une
télévision un robot multifonction ou un
centre de repassage avec les mains je
sais pas ce que ça veut dire quoi sévère
c'est à dire tu repasses elle est comme
ça tu vois pas toi c'est à dire je fais
ça rires regardez votre physique
[Applaudissements]
le veau comme ça c'est clair comme green
le mien est froissé également non vous
ne peut rien faire c'est l'âge
alors oui mais alors c'est très simple
vous avez vous mettre derrière une
fenêtre et je tirerai le rideau mais
nepton est près de moi sandra parce que
je veux pas que vous ayez des détritus
ce sait où il y a un beau cadeau ou bien
il ya une tarte à la crème c'est bien
sûr letarte et fenêtres benjamin
castaldi ou vous mettez derrière la 3 la
croix vous êtes sûr pas écouté façon je
vais la prendre dans la gueule non non
non vous avez vous avez deux chances sur
trois de la prod était vous bien bien
bien il en train de ces accords ok alors
c'est ou un cadeau ou une tarte
attention 3 2 1
[Applaudissements]
benjamin cassaniouze à gros nez vous
faire chier dessus par le grand
schtroumpf
merci à marie malheureusement oui mais
je veux quand même un cadeau est ce que
vous voulez une télévision un écran bah
voilà bah c'est pour moi c'est cadeau on
n'a pas été très bons on n'a pas très
bien joué avec qui veut jouer il va
falloir jouer sinon je vais désigné
s'arrête aussi simple que ça allait
réjouit jean alesi c'est vrai une boîte
voilà comme ça on fait voilà les poneys
venez nous rejoindre
attention c'est le tarif net je vous le
rappelle bonsoir quand vous appelez sa
valise à 8,6 bien longtemps que les
abeilles sont magnifiques non mais c'est
vrai vraiment je dis ça aussi pour
isabelle morini bosc et au public
regardez puis surveille briquet et voilà
qu établi en bordeau chesnel qu'est ce
qu'on fait dans la ville l'assistante
maternelle des supers s'être marié
fiancée marié il est là oui il est dans
le public
oui enfin on peut le voir ouais vous
avez longtemps combien d'enfants de 502
en prison qu'à l'âge alors j'ai un grand
garçon romain qui à 23 ans la brasse
euro ont la gnac san qui à 18 sans débat
alors on leur associe voilà et j'ai bien
bien non dagan j'adore et je suis ouvre
de guingamp vous le savez le parvis
olala j'embrasse tous les guingampais
d'ailleurs su actionnaires du club
voilà donc je te lis voilà je kiffe ce
club voilà je kiffe attention j'ai envie
celle ben oui on va jouer et vous allez
pouvoir faire gagner un très beau cadeau
aimerait bien peut-être pas et là je
vous le dis si ça payera pas lequel
parce que il j'ai eu des remords ans de
la régie les gens m'ont insulté jean
michel maire ou choisissez quoi je vais
prendre là là deux là 2b quelle garantie
g que les gens bougent pas derrière
alors je vous le jure je vous assure et
qui rassure et alana ils ont même pas
l'idée capter non je vous jure encore
non on n'est pas sûr ambitieux un peu
qu'on le dépeint dans des bas comme ça
alors mis ses garanties par cyril ça va
le forum il aurait voulu rassurer
d'abord il n'y a pas fait attention jean
michel vous choisissez la 2 vous êtes
sûr pourquoi pas à ce que je vous
demande
oui mais pourquoi vous me demandez ce
que la douce qui sont perdantes est une
gagnante
oui mais vous me conseillez panda 2 à
moi moi moi non bah je prends la douleur
moi je vous possèdent pas de problème de
l'oeuf et ouais mais je le prendrais de
huf d'accord parce que je connais votre
côté le fourbe vous allez connaître
en attendant donc on s'est vraiment
prenez une je conseille d'attendre la
deux non vraiment c'est votre réponse
définitive
je prends la doller vous aviez vous
preniez la une mais j'ai changé j'ai vu
dans votre attention
vous auriez choisi quoi vous
la une à une alors il choisit la une à
la tentation ça glisse sympa je vais lui
faire plaisir alors alors vous allez
prendre je ne veux pas qu'elle ait des
regrets oui moi je vous avais dit de ne
pas prendre la 2 bat moins jeunes en
tout cas j'ai promis qu'elle avait
regret alors on va on va voir tout de
suite ce qu'il y avait derrière la 2g
yves ne pas prendre la 2 e à ça c'est
bon c'était une tarte en classe le
cadeau peut-être où il est peut-être là
moi je vais faire une tarte à bord est
alors échangé avant partie un virage
avec var à zéro à chaque fois
et pas du tout la bière ou un cadeau ou
une tarte non la mer talent et on n'a
jamais vu ça mais non on repart à zéro
[Musique]
vous conseillez quoi moi je vous ai
juste conseillé de prendre la 2 a
d'accord moi je prendrai une combat
parce que je vais écouter il a bel et
bien jean michel vous avez énormément de
chance
[Applaudissements]
et dalal à trois derrière la 3 il y
avait un cadeau y avait un duo évasion
pour partir en vacances et ouais encore
40 ouest c'était le duo évasion grâce à
notre partenaire et bien sûr je vous
l'offre
vous partez en week end et personnes
avec votre mari sa désir est gentil je
m'investis dit
leers matière non